la chronique de l'écho qui se poursuit
en ce jeudi on va changer de thématiques
à présent une meilleure mobilité
peut-elle faciliter la recherche
d'emploi c'est la question qu'on va se
poser et oui on peut aussi cette
chronique économie avec la création de
la plateforme bouger vers l'emploi il
s'agit d'un dispositif qui vise à aider
les demandeurs d'emploi a dépassé leurs
contraintes de mobilité et donc à
retrouver plus facilement un emploi
je me répète ces dispositifs a été créé
par l'association voiture enhco nous
allons voir en ligne dans un instant le
directeur régional emmanuel igo mais
avant notre question du jour pour lancer
cette thématique le manque de mobilité
est ce un frein à la recherche d'emploi
on se retrouve juste après donc et nous
aurons en ligne le directeur régional de
voitures enhco je pense que c'est un
frein énorme énorme à l'emploi et que le
français plutôt casanier mais il faut
savoir qu'ils ont jusqu'à un certain âge
est mobile je pense que c'est un facteur
fondamental de toute façon la situation
est déjà très difficile et même avec de
la mobilité je suis pas convaincu qu'on
arrive à retrouver du boulot vu qu'il
n'a pas au niveau national c'est parce
qu'il fait le marché du travail en fait
ça doit dépendre de l'agglomération dans
laquelle vous vivez puisque si vous êtes
dans une petite commune est loin du
centre ville forcément ça va vous poser
plus de problèmes que si vous êtes dans
une grande agglomération avec bus métros
et ceux qui sont très excentré mais
c'est sûrement un problème pour être aux
heures d'ouverture dans les centres de
recherche d'emploi c'est pas toujours
facile de pouvoir déménager quand on a
une famille quand on a des enfants etc
mais
dans certains cas je pense qu'il ya
certaines personnes qui peuvent le faire
plus facilement
on retrouve emmanuelle rigaud le
directeur régional de l'association
voiture enhco
oui bonsoir merci d'être en ligne avec
nous ce soir pour le 7 8 alors je je
pense que vous avez entendu la question
du jour les les personnes sont assez
unanimes sur la question la mobilité
est un frein à l'emploi à l'emploi c'est
bien pour ça que voiture et le co a
appelé revient depuis 2005 sur cette
thématique la mobilité notamment alors
nous on aide les demandeurs d'emploi à
lever les freins à développer une
autonomie soit en capacité de nous
déplacer
car les freins à la mobilité sont de
deux types sont soit des freins matériel
j'ai complètement pas de véhicule
d'année d'après un brin b alors que j'ai
le permis ou comme les placer en deux
mois donc on va faire la location
sociale pour permettre à une personne
qui n'a pas le permis d'un deux roues et
personne quelqu'un linking voiture pour
pouvoir accéder à l'emploi et tu
voudrais aussi des freins qui peuvent
être des freins psychologiques sa tête
et cartes mentales qui limite vos
déplacements je vais prendre un exemple
j'habite magny les hameaux j'ai besoin
d'aller sur lui en cours je me persuade
que je peux pas sortir de cette zone que
je n'arrive pas à accéder à guyancourt
et pourtant il ya en 40 minutes la
possibilité d'y accéder on pourra
toujours trouver une solution pour
réduire ce temps 40 minutes n'est pas
non plus énorme mais c'est comment
j'arrive à déplacer à dépasser mais mes
freins psychologiques pour pouvoir me
déplacer où on à pas lents que certains
demandent emploi qui arrivent sur le
territoire qui viennent d'un autre pays
connaissent pas le réseau de transport
en commun en ile de france comment on
peut l'utiliser comment je peux me
déplacer le débat fait franc je fais
tout l'objectif de voitures locaux à
travers des actions pédagogiques ou la
location matériel alors justement ces
solutions pédagogiques au matériel
quelles sont elles alors quand on
repense on reçoit quelqu'un qui voulait
pressé par des partenaires sofia tu fais
que mon travail l'entaillé avec les
trois structures d'insertion voilà un
pôle emploi et la mission locale voilà
le tous les partenaires le coton est
partenaire voix or une presse libre
lorsque identifions contraint de
mobilité dans certaines filières précise
la personne on la retrouvera et on fait
avec elle intègre nautique mobilité nous
confier mobilité prennent le temps pour
définir avec elle et chars en sorte
qu'ils triment et la contrainte de
mobilité à partir de là on définit un
plan d'accompagnement ce plan
d'accompagnement il peut proposer de vue
leurs actions sa tête des formations
donc des formations traitent comment je
me suis mis mes déplacements en
utilisant internet par exemple internet
est un outil qui a fait peut l'utiliser
mine de rien pour se déplacer que c'est
une vraie solution comment j'apprends à
lire une carte comment j'apprends à
me repérer dans les transports en commun
alors que je ne sais pas
comment je prends confiance en moi pour
prendre les transports en commun
qu'elles sont parfois une attention très
peur après les transports en commun
comment gelé fin on a aussi des
formations pour mettre en avant les avec
les beaucoup de personnes ne connaissent
pas les aides qui leur permettrait de
faciliter leurs déplacements ou par
exemple verrait femmes par exemple à
gaza voilà il y avait seulement des dz
plus prix matériel comme par exemple le
prêt de véhicules ou de vélo voilà après
on va mettre à disposition un parc de
véhicules qui vont du vélo clients
parfaite petite réflexion j'ai un vélo
pliant depuis je rends dans leur auberge
le déplie j'ai fait à mon emploi est
aussi une classique des vélos à
assistance électrique un petit moteur
électrique des scooters électriques
on peut avoir des scooters thermiques
ils avaient voiture et dans l'est sur
les tarifs sociaux qui par exemple pour
une voiture sans l'auteur de 4 euros par
jour
qui paiera mettre effectivement à la
personne d'accéder à l'emploi mais nous
en parallèle voiture et qu on fait en
sorte de lui trouver une solution
pérenne nous on est là pour initier une
dynamique pour être autonome dans ses
déplacements on n'est pas là pour
accompagner sur du très long terme et en
parallèle on accompagne la personne
puisse faire l'acquisition d'une voiture
par exemple avec une produit
alors alors vous venez de vous installer
dans les yvelines c'est une première je
ne sais par contre déjà présent en ile
de france est ce que vous auriez des
données sur la région de personnes que
vous accompagnez de taux de réussite
aujourd'hui on
les quatre structures qui fonctionnent
de france vont permettre d'être
compagnie à peu près de 1700 personnes
sur l'année et on a globalement sur son
intervention en national un peu
d'accompagnement qui est de 42 50 %
entre des personnes reçues il est rond
qu'il retourne à lens a donc l'idée
vraiment leur faut pas non plus sur un
territoire comme la communauté
d'agglomération
saint-quentin-en-yvelines fil d'arrivée
afin qu'on pourra en voir de le dépasser
avec bien sûr toujours
une dernière question pour ceux qui se
sont retrouvés dans la description que
vous avez pu faire de ces problèmes de
mobilité qui sont concernés qui veulent
bénéficier de vos services de voitures
et une courbe de la plateforme bouger
vers l'emploi il faut se tourner vers
qui comment ça fonctionne alors le plus
simple étant se retourner vers les
institutions comme pôle emploi les
missions locales et fonctions furent aux
mairies sont les partenaires qui revient
en fait notre action si vous voulez nous
contacter en direct nous avons ensuite
interné de cette voiture est qu ils ont
le plus simple en local nous sommes en
train de faire après communication en
direct auprès de pôle emploi missions
locales les mairies les fonds sociaux
tous les acteurs sociaux connaît et puis
ce site internet voiture une co vous
l'avez mentionné mon avis d'ailleurs
quelques images pendant que vous pariez
que vous nous expliquer cette
problématique merci à vous on poursuit
cette chronique de l'écho avec les infos
en plus à présent et oui les premiers
contrats d'avenir ont été signés par la
communauté d'agglomération de
saint-quentin-en-yvelines la casse qui
donc la première agglomération à
s'engager au niveau national on compte
dans le département dix mille deux cent
soixante jeunes de moins de 25 ans qui
sont inscrits à pôle emploi et puis pour
rappel les contrats d'avenir sont
destinés à des jeunes qui sont
déscolarisés ou avec peu de diplômes ils
sont financés à 75 % par l'état on en
avait parlé la semaine dernière sur ce
plateau le cinéma d'elancourt qui
commençait à être inquiet avec
l'éventualité d'un nouveau cinéma du
côté de maurepas et la décision est
tombée finalement est oui alors michel
chabanne autres invités de la semaine
dernière était assez confiant
malheureusement la commission nationale
d'aménagement commercial a refusé le
projet
donc rejeté il devait en fait
s'installer au village de loisirs de
paris ouest il s'agissait de huit salles
de cinéma le projet avait déjà été
refusé deux fois par la commission
départementale il s'agissait donc du
dernier opus malheureusement pour paris
ouest et heureusement pour le signer 7 à
elancourt qui vient de rouvrir et qu'il
sera satisfait de voir qu'un nouveau
concurrent à proximité la dernière info
en plus ce soir elle concerne tous les
ménages oui alors c'est pas une
information propre divine mais elle
concerne évidemment les yvelinois comme
chaque année les prestations sociales ou
augmentent ou éthérée aussi le 1er avril
la hausse reste cependant limitée la
faute à l'inflation notamment qui est
qu'il est que de 1,2 pour cent cette
année les allocations familiales
augmente à ce même taux 1,2 pour cent
les pensions de retraite augmente l de
1,3 pour cent mais dans le secteur privé
les retraites complémentaires
n'augmenteront que de 0,5 à 0,8 pour
cent les syndicats ont en effet accepté
une d'aisance et dessins je vais y
arriver à laisser votre souffle réalisé
désindexation là c'est pas facile les
dents temporaires nouvelle a le temps de
redresser les comptes des
indexations
passe à la jambe à deux dates à noter
deux dates à noter dans les noms
d'acteurs non excusez moi évidemment de
date donc premier un atelier sur la
retraite mode d'emploi c'est à
destination des salariés du privé quand
partir à la retraite quel droit à voir
et puis aussi comment reprendre une
activité une fois à la retraite
puisqu'il ya aussi des retraités qui
travaillent ou toutes les informations à
la cité des métiers à trappes lundi 8
avril de 10 heures à 13 heures et puis
une deuxième date à retenir un zoom sur
les métiers de l'exposition et de
l'événementiel ou par exemple pour
monter un salon pour créer un stand ou
en événements ce sera à la cité des
métiers égale des métiers de trappes
également le jeudi 11 avril de 14h30 à
16h30 merci claire jeudi prochain avec
des mots un peu moins compliqué que ça
sera plus simple on prendra moins de
risques on passe aux sports pour
conclure ce set suite de ce 4 avril